well today so thank you for coming to
our panel on social entrepreneurship we
have four great panelists here today who
you'll get to hear a lot from we have
here Jed Smith who is managing director
of Catamount ventures Kristin grosse
Richmond the founder of revolution foods
Peter Frick Minh founder of drip tech
and those to our social entrepreneurs
and Russ Hall a co-founder of legacy
ventures so we have two social
entrepreneurs and two investors so we
should get a good rounded perspective on
this
my name is Gina jerash I'm director of
the public management program at here at
the Business School you know you should
also know that Russ an investor in my
fund that's an investor in revolution
foods and yes we all can that's why we
care yeah and they'll soon be investing
in Peter I hope so before we get into
the panel itself I just wanted to set a
little context because social
entrepreneurship means different things
to different people and in fact when
they asked me to moderate this panel I
was thinking of something entirely
different so I thought I would start
just by all entrepreneurs are social
entrepreneurs in one way they all create
value they all create jobs they create
products and services that hopefully the
market needs so we're not talking about
so yes all entrepreneurs are social
entrepreneurs but social entrepreneurs
create additional social or
environmental value somewhere in the
value chain and and so I put a peer sort
of where might a social enterprise
create that kind of value and this is
based off michael Porter's seven steps
in the value chain you know some
examples might be in a world of good
some of you might be familiar with they
create social value in the value chain
by sourcing products from third world
artists from artisans in the third world
and providing a market access to the
first world for them to provide
additional economic opportunities so
that's how they create social value
social value can be created in the
employment stage not just employing
people but employing people who might
otherwise not be able to get jobs such
as the disabled incarcerated or
something like that an example here
might be the YMCA
who employs many disabled people the
social value can be created in the
design part of the company such as
delight a company that has created an
extremely affordable light for people in
very remote rural areas that can't that
don't have electricity so they've
created a social value by providing a
product specifically for their needs the
value can be created in the production
or the delivery such as company
providing locally grown food which
reduces the carbon footprint or creating
or producing a product in a more
environmentally friendly way such as
what a Kia does in the way they produce
their products to minimise waste and
minimize transportation costs the social
value might be created by taking normal
products and providing them to a
previously underserved market like
banking for the poor which is
essentially what microfinance does and
finally social value might just be
created by donating a percent of profits
to to nonprofit organizations so a
social enterprise might engage in any
one or all or a certain amounts of value
creation in this value chain and so
hopefully we'll hear a little bit about
what these folks are doing and so what
we're total Enterprise and social
entrepreneurship covers a broad spectrum
starting with on the Left there's
nonprofits which do mission maximization
and on the other side there's for
profits that focus on profit
maximization and then there's sort of a
gray area in the middle that might be
nonprofits that have revenue streams or
that otherwise operate like businesses
and for profits that have a mission I
have maybe a double or triple bottom
line so for today's panel we're
primarily focused on that piece of the
spectrum which is for-profit enterprises
that have a social mission and so some
of the things that we'd like to
understand today on the panel are what
are some of unique challenges of running
this kind of a social enterprise what
are the capital what is the capital
market like for them when they want to
go out and raise money and grow their
organization and how might that be
changing so that's that's what we're
going to talk about
so now for the panel I'd like you guys
to each introduce yourself if you could
tell us a little bit about what inspired
you to start your venture or to start
funding these kind of ventures give a
brief description of your organization
and how do you create social value Jen
briefly I'll start at the end and then
go to the beginning and then come back
to the end so I I currently run a
venture capital fund called Catamount
ventures we have about two hundred and
twenty-five million dollars under
management and our primary focus how we
do some technology is focused on
investing in companies that have
products or services that are better for
the environment across the board across
almost every sector of the economy and
how I got there I spent 12 years as an
entrepreneur starting companies one did
well one didn't do well and one did
really well I learned as much from the
failures as as the successes and then
started doing venture capital about 10
years ago and really feel like the only
way I was able to do my job or have been
able to do my job is because of the
operating experience that I had and
having gone through the creative process
of what it takes to start a company and
make it work after about five or six
years of doing venture capital mostly in
the technology space I wanted to kind of
move on and save the world from doom and
you know I just wasn't happy where
everything was and and and thought about
lots of different interesting
not-for-profit ideas and and and
concepts and and every time I kept
bumping in was like well I have to raise
money to do that and I'm gonna have to
get the right people to do that and then
I saw what a lot of the venture
capitalists were doing in 2003 and four
and five investing in alternative energy
and I felt like you know that's just one
piece of the puzzle that the issues
around sustainability hit every single
sector of our economy whether it is food
energy water air building materials
everything if people think about you
know the impact of their purchasing
decisions and so therefore have been
spending the last five years looking at
all of the different opportunities that
are in my mind very exciting both from a
capitalists perspective as well as
from a impact on the world
great I'm Kristin Richmond I'm the
co-founder and CEO of revolution foods
revolution foods seeks to transform the
way we feed our students nationwide so
we started with the goal of bringing
healthy fresh nutritious delicious
affordable meals to schools and what
inspired me to do that well I have a
mixed background actually started in
finance and then moved to education and
I spent a lot of time in schools both
abroad and here in California and mostly
schools serving underserved students and
would constantly I'm a pretty
entrepreneurial spirit and would
constantly be asking what are some of
your greatest needs and the number of
times that I heard access to decent not
even healthy fresh but just decent food
options in schools I think the most
defining moment was when I heard a
teacher at a Kipp school say I just feel
like a flat-out hypocrite because I sit
in a classroom and I teach my kids one
thing around how to take care of their
body what they eat fuels their wellness
their academic achievement how they're
performing out there on the sports field
and then we go down to the lunchroom and
I'm serving them taco pockets and
Cheetos and I just I don't like feeling
like this no one likes feeling like this
there's got to be a better solution and
that you know very very common story
unfortunately that kind of sums up a big
part of the inspiration there is a huge
need a huge demand for a healthier
option for our kids you know what
inspires us is bridging that access gap
so certainly we feel like every student
out there deserves a healthy meal
you know revolution foods does focus
primarily in underserved schools where
there is an even larger access gap so a
little bit about us so my name is Peter
Frick man I'm the founder of drip tech
and CEO basically we make low-cost drip
irrigation for small farmers in
developing countries and how I got into
that my backgrounds in mechanical
engineering so I did my undergraduate
and
graduate work at Stanford and towards
the end of my graduate school I realized
that I really needed to do something
that was both engineering intensive and
entrepreneurial but also had a strong
social impact so I was looking for ways
to to get all three of those and I was
looking at medical device design and a
couple other avenues but ended up
getting involved in a course called
entrepreneurial design for extreme
affordability at the d.school
and this this course is starting to get
a good reputation for developing
enabling technologies and notable
notable companies have been founded out
of it such as delight and embrace and
and now now us as well
I basically as part of the course was
able to go to Ethiopia and interview
farmers understand a little bit about
what their needs were during the dry
season we saw that that they they really
suffered from from water scarcity and
needed modern drip irrigation but the
current solutions on the market weren't
appropriate they didn't scale down to
fit the needs of these rural farmers so
we looked at what was being done on the
space with help from a lot of advisors
and partners and ended up developing a
new manufacturing technology which
allows us to make low-cost drip
irrigation locally and and provided to
them so I founded the company actually
did a lot of development of our business
plan through GSB course as 3:56 and then
I just got back from from China and
India we we've just installed our first
200 systems 200 farms in a rural village
in China and closed a small round of
angel dust so I'll try to be brief and
and it could be confusing too because I
could span both the social entrepreneur
and the the investor side I was first
here in these seats 31 years ago as a
business school student those of you
that are here at the business school
made Oh Dan Rudolph my classmate
and may have bumped into a Steve Ballmer
and Rich Fairbanks and some others in in
a in a fun class that was here after a
number of careers in the valley some
startups and venture capital about 11
years ago I started with a venture
capital friend of mine legacy venture
and the thought there was a number of us
were donating and when we donated a
great currency to donate with our tax
code is highly appreciated stock well
how do you get it other than being lucky
and we decided that if you could get
into the best venture funds they would
have a better track record of being able
to deliver highly appreciated stock and
all of our investors promised everything
they they would invest and whatever
became of it they would give away and
that allowed us to get into the best
venture funds and so we've been able to
get investments through them and to
PayPal and YouTube and Netflix and and
hopefully the future we may get some
liquidity with Facebook and Bloom Energy
and Silver Spring and revolution foods
that were all invested in so and all
those proceeds will go to the
philanthropy of each investors choice
the second part though is we don't
believe philanthropy is particularly
well understood or practiced and in fact
what we're talking about today investing
in social entrepreneurs is one field of
that that could be vastly improved and
the good news is it is there's a lot of
happening
well if it can be improved how do you do
it and our approach and it's one among
many is to build a safe peer-to-peer
community where we can talk among each
other about what we're doing and we hope
at the end of the day not only do we
have more to do philanthropy with but we
do a better job and so some of our
investors so for instance I'll brag on a
few of them is the tech museum the tech
museum has anointed Peter here who
humbly didn't put it as a tech laureate
one of the brightest social
entrepreneurs around that around the
world so it actually does come full
circle a little bit that the there's
already an event so I thought I'd and
another of our investors Bob Pattillo
who runs something called Grey Ghost of
Atlanta is a big investor in indie light
and has been taking that too so some of
our investors are already with it and
already doing some things others are in
process so
we're hoping that that would go along I
guess that's enough or start other than
I'll say that in the value chain there
when you get down to the the end of it
we we do something unique with our fees
one we don't have a carry so that all
goes to our philanthropist to give away
and of our fees we we take some of that
and we steer it into a 501c3 a public
foundation and we we invest that and
this is where the confusing part is we
also have a foundation called legacy
works and that's invested in among other
things
good capital and good capital is
invested in Edina beverages started by
Greg Stanton Pohl who did wala
and is also working on obesity but more
on the campus side and better World
Books which some of you may use for
recycling textbooks here on campus so
Russ touches this in many different
directions ok so I have a couple of
questions for the social entrepreneurs
first Peter can you give us one example
of when the desire for a double bottom
line might have conflicted with your
profit maximization and how did you
resolve that conflict that's that's a
great question I I get this question a
lot I think that that we're very
fortunate because our our product
inherently contains the social impact
you know the our drip irrigation is
really an enabling technology for these
farmers that lets them grow a second or
third crop during the dry season and
increases their income possibly their
nutrition and so the social impact is
really built into our product and to the
extent that we can really maximize our
profitability and expand to offer that
value proposition as many people as
possible that's how we see also acts
amaizing our social impact so we don't
really see a trade-off
per se between profitability and social
impact maximization so if I look at this
slide here you're saying because you are
in this sort of design and production
you're its inherent in your product you
don't
have to compromise that's that's the
good thing about so it might be
interesting for some of you considering
social enterprises to think about where
you're getting your value from and it's
at a tougher way or is there a higher
expense involved in that where these
trade-offs might come into play because
I think Kristin has a similar story to
Peter perhaps well I think we certainly
have the are so I want to use that term
inherent I mean that's the revolution
foods our social mission is inherent in
what we do I mean we're providing
healthier meals and nutrition education
to students certainly we've made some
choices around which students we focus
on so when we think about you know our
portfolio of schools about 80 percent of
the students we serve are low-income
students and are qualifying for the free
and reduced lunch program so are
dependent upon national and state
subsidies as many of you know there's an
incredible effort led by Michelle Obama
right now to significantly increase
those subsidies so that's the most
exciting thing going on in our world
right now but it's a you know certainly
a lot of folks look at our product and
say well you know you could take this
product and charge twice as much as you
do and serve it to private school
students for instance and truthfully I
mean I'm going to agree with Peter in a
way that we have seen a huge opportunity
from a business perspective in you know
serving the students that we serve and
really addressing the need in the market
sector that we have addressed and we
think you know it's not only a great
decision socially but also a really it's
also where a massive opportunity lies
for us because it really hasn't been
addressed in a great way and I'm trying
to think of other can make it be able to
give a few specific example it's a good
point actually um we we get questioned
all the time you know people ask us Kim
well can i buy the system in the US you
know what this for my backyard you
should sell this you can you can make
great margins in the US and you know
it's true the first place we got it
working was my backyard and Palo Alto
but it's not our focus and it's it's not
it's not really the business the market
opportunity
choosing to limit your target market to
the people who are underserved or less
well served go ahead yeah I think I have
a little different perspective I'll use
another company that we're an investor
in as an example but I think it would
relate we're an investment company
called seventh generation which is a
consumer products company with recycled
paper towels and diapers and cleaning
products and laundry detergents etc it's
about one hundred and fifty million
dollar company and I I don't even love
the term double bottom line or triple
bottom line because almost because this
slide identifies a wonderfully we're
looking for compasses that think about
sustainability across everything that
they do and it's not it you can't just
do one and not the other you can't you
have to think about it from the broad
perspective in order to be authentic and
what you're doing but if you're truly
authentic then you wouldn't buy any of
these products right if you're truly
authentic you wouldn't have a car you do
you grow your veggies in your backyard
and and and so I think that these
companies if they're run appropriately
in the way that that we like to invest
in companies that think about it this
way is that they think about the tension
between sustainability and profit and
across everything that they do because
you can't have the most perfect
compostable packaging because it may not
be the most profitable way to do it and
so maybe you push up a little bit on
procurement and supply chain we go out
and look at all of the best possible
suppliers at seven generation around the
world and and there's always kind of a
fine line between we want to get the
best possible margins we can but we also
so you know at all of it design our name
seven generation is you know all about
thinking through the impact of your
decisions on seven seven generations
from now on production on delivery and
we're trying to reduce our carbon
footprint on target market and who cares
about this kind of stuff and then we
donate ten percent of our profits to to
nonprofit and community causes so I
think that at least in the venture
capital world in private company world
you can find pure companies that are
authentic and everything that they do
and it's much more difficult to do that
with Procter and Gamble or Clorox or
General Electric or Walmart that may
have interesting
initiatives but they can't change
everything they do they still have to
sell their Clorox Clorox bleach and I
have I have a little follow-up too from
from my perspective with revolution
foods I mean we're building two things
we're building a financially successful
company and that's really important to
us we're also building a brand that's
really important to us and that brand
you know ultimately has you know as much
or more value and I think it's it's so
important that we make decisions
consistent with our brand every single
step of the way and sometimes that may
cost more and sometimes that may be
slightly you know may may affect your
margin by point or whatever it is but
you've got to focus on that brand
first and foremost and for us that brand
inherent in our brand is that social
mission and all of it is is on every one
of these steps at least in my experience
is where do you draw the line and that
gets unbelievably difficult because you
can go all the way or you know halfway
or you know I'm weird at revolution food
just like we're not all organic you know
because we can because their business
model would not hold up but you know we
don't have any hormones in the meat and
you can talk about the food quality so
that that tension is always there on
every step of this chain okay
for the social entrepreneurs again can
you tell us a little bit about how you
got funded and how you were continuing
to get funded and what were some of the
challenges there okay I'll start so um
we found it after after the course ended
so we founded in June 2008 and that
summer we pursued some fundings and
financing we got our first funding in
terms of a couple thousand dollars of
donations and then and then a little bit
bigger chunk in terms of angel
investment and then since then we've
we've consistently added angel investors
we once we got our first sales in China
last summer we are our investors were
pretty pleased with SNA they sort of
spearheaded a round of angel investment
where they reached out with to their
network of apply net worth individuals
and wealthy technologists in the Bay
Area and basically through
through some networking we we ended up
raising an angel round it was pretty
interesting because we were only looking
for a couple hundred thousand dollars
and and we talked a lot of people in the
sort of social VC space who basically
said that that we were crazy to try to
raise that amount of money because it
was sort of too large for angel
investors and too small for institutions
but what we saw was that there was
really a latent demand for the type of
investment that we were providing and we
ended up not having any trouble raising
angel angel Capital and we're in fact
heavily oversubscribed in our recent
recent round great so it's funny I have
a very similar sort of Peter in terms of
where my partner Kirsten and I started
we went to Haas right down the road and
we spent our entire business school
focused on building the business plan
for revolution foods and that meant not
just you know writing a business plan
but literally being out in the field
every single day meeting with schools
and community stakeholders around what
we were putting together we also managed
to form a strategic partnership with
Whole Foods which has been phenomenal
and get our first school customers on
board so that was and really importantly
we launched a pilot program so I think
when I think back to kind of how how we
got funded in that first step being able
to connect investors with the actual you
know food and school scene and students
really brought it to life
our first funders were Barry equity fund
and they it's really interesting as you
think about business plans that you
could start they were very interested in
us not only for health and wellness but
they have a mandate and their Charter
that says that they have to invest in
companies that promote job creation in
low to moderate income areas well a very
important part of revolution foods you
know outside of the health and wellness
aspect is our job creation and our
commitment to fair jobs and the fact
that we locate ourselves in underserved
communities and have we have about 250
employees now 80% of which fit this
profile of folks coming from you know
low-wage jobs we pay
of liveable wage we offer full health
benefits and a chance to own part of our
company so that part of our mission
really appealed to them and they saw an
opportunity for job creation and that
was sort of what sealed our our seed
round since then we've been able to
connect with you know investors like Jed
the Wesley group people who are very
focused on sustainability and that's
been a fantastic Avenue to to tell our
story and raise money
most recently we're seeing some very
interesting crossover between the
foundation and venture capital world in
the sense that we are because of our
social mission we're talking to folks
like Kellogg Foundation and Gates
Foundation and people out there who
found a shion's out there who are really
interested in the MRI mission-related
investing sector so I think once again
if you think about starting a social
venture another plus is you're able to
cross those capital worlds that you
might not normally be able to do so
that's you know that's been a little bit
of our story crystal made a good point
about about the value of a pilot program
absolutely true in our case as well we
had a we had a functional prototype of
our manufacturing technology before we
raised any money and then and then the
first money we raised was really to run
a pilot program and and you know pilot
program led to our first sales and the
sales lead or you know angel round it it
was it was incredibly important like
very what role did friends and family
play in the very early stages we didn't
actually happen to have well I'd say we
had a lot of support from friends and
family especially my family I guess they
invested in a way that sort of
supporting some of our you know expenses
and and not as a direct investor in the
company but but just in sort of a
supportive investor in me perhaps the
question is how much have your
respective business schools faculty
you know other relationships directly
coming out your business school we I
mean well we've definitely had friends
and family invest in every round and
that's that's really important to us
it's you know certainly and helped us
along our way and and been critical
because we're a pretty asset intensive
business we required a little bit more
startup capital than our friends and
family could put out there so we did
need to secure a more sizable round in
the beginning than we could raise from
our friends and family did want to
mention one other thing you know Kirsten
I did spend some time in the very
beginning thinking about a strategic
investment from a large food company got
pretty long pretty far along the way
with an investment like that from a big
food company and realized right before
they were about to sign the deal they
said oh by the way you have to include
10,000 units of this product that's
filled with sugary syrup whatever and
we're like okay we won't be doing that
so I just I think there are you know and
thank God we did it I mean it you know
not consistent at all with what we were
doing but you know another another thing
to take advantage of but really be
careful of who those first investors are
so I I wanted to ask the investors a
question so the social entrepreneurs
come to you full of commitment and
passion for their for their mission does
that scare you off how much do you want
to hear them talk about the business and
the profitability versus the mission how
do you how do you think about how they
presented and also how do you look at
the returns do you anticipate that
they'll be lower returns or slower
returns that will be taking longer to
get your money back yes and yes
they and it goes back to what Kristin
was saying with one of these the we've
started to evolve our thinking and I'll
speak I'll put on the hats of some of
our investors that do this although it's
still very nascent it's still very early
days and there are some steps that
evolve especially if you're investing
out of a foundation that have had to be
sanctified as a fiduciary wise investor
to be able to do that and for that you
have the emergence of one of the two
what they call TL A's three-letter
acronyms it
used in the in the field MRIs and PR is
PR is sort of codify what Gina was
heading at with the less than market
rates lower too so that's something
that's aligned with our program or if
Kellogg we're here why we'll get to
Kalamazoo if they met offhand that it's
not going to be a market rate of return
but because it falls into that basket
they're able to do it if it is market
rate of return then they can do MRIs
that the market rate returns and so some
of these are part of a continuum Kellogg
thinks market rate of return is our
market related investments to week of
work so they use MD is mission driven
investment as opposed to mission related
investment and by the way on all of this
on these asset classes I'll just make
reference to this and you come down
later look at or go online there are two
wonderful guides both freely
downloadable at the Rockefeller
philanthropy advisors website one called
one on MRI is called philanthropies
passing gear MRIs and then the most
recent one solution for impact investors
because this name is changing as we go
and in it in the especially in this one
this is written by a couple of our
investors that do that and edit it and
also back by a number of our investors
they have in here a very informative
chart that tries to lay out passion area
by compassion Airy whether its
environment or education or curing
poverty or obesity or what health
whatever it is what are we seeing evolve
as some of the investments you can make
across a whole spectrum of asset classes
so whether it's fixed income all the way
and in this case we're talking about the
more risky private equity deal so that
but that's I have about 20 copies here
if you want to come by later and even
get some of my panels and easily and
I'll just say that I've read I read this
actually and it was pretty good yeah
well I I have two answers one would be
how Catamount looks at it and one would
be I guess
a little more globally speaking on
Catamount we're looking for both we're
absolutely looking for world-class
game-changing entrepreneurs and
companies that want to change the world
and what they're doing whatever segments
that they're playing in and as well as
people that have a tremendous passion
and have an authentic peer review about
how they treat their employees and their
customers and their packaging and all of
it so we're I'm looking for I'm not
looking for one more than the other I'm
not looking for the idea and then the
model I'm looking for both all of them
put together there are plenty of great
investors who are more mission driven
and if they could be investing in
for-profit or not-for-profit entities
and that's that's okay it's just not
what we're doing the reason why we're
doing it the way we are is because I
think it's a unique time in history in
the stuff that we're looking at where
you can do both exceedingly well and
there are tremendous opportunities and I
don't think it's a fad I think this is a
long you know 10 20 year Movement so I
think that my interesting point I just
want it that one I think you're right
that there is a time a period of time
right now where you can have the sort of
the a-class organizations who are doing
the same thing everybody else was doing
but doing it better and cleaner and all
of that now and you can cream off the
top and they've got the profits and
they've got the mission right I wonder
how long that'll last before before you
know the best ones have been picked off
and and from an investment perspective
like I I think it's going to be a while
I don't know I really do think every
sector of our economy is going to change
and I think the new Procter & Gamble's
and the new era mark and Sodexo's you
know they're going to come from
revolution food and they're going to
come from seventh generation they're
going to come from emerging companies
that will that will be the powerhouses
in 10 or 20 years and I think we're
expanding not only the definition of
what a business is to include more
socially responsible concept as an
inherent part of the business so I think
that will widen the funnel and then to
at the same time we're widening the tap
of social entrepreneurs that want to do
it as the infrastructure builds more
coming into it I wanted to underscore
something jet-set just so it doesn't get
lost if you do have a social enterprise
and whether you're coming into a
hard-nosed for-profit kind of we want to
make yes you have to do good
but we're going to look at it or the
better practitioners that are on maybe
the less than market rate return they
will still and what this is what's
something that we encourage them to do
and these books do too is still have
their business hat on and so they will
look at you and don't say hey we're
doing great things do you really care
about this stuff no they want to know do
you have management you know are you is
your business plan competent you know
will it can you reach a scale at which
things can be sustainable and you can
operate so they should be asking the
same hard questions whether it's on the
totally social side or the for-profit
side so don't expect to kind of get a
pass just because you're doing something
good so I want to point something else
everybody so if you look at this chart
here it's hard to find the social
entrepreneurs to come on a panel like
this because very few call themselves
for-profit social entrepreneurs either
because for investors they're just
calling themselves entrepreneurs or if
they're or often social entrepreneurs
consider themselves put themselves in
the nonprofit bucket so I kind of
adjusting what both of you are where
you're all saying is social
entrepreneurs who are for-profit are
addressing both the profit side and the
mission side and so you know they kind
of they cover the full spectrum so it's
a it's really interesting for my
perspective because just finishing this
angel round we've probably got almost
two dozen different angel investors at
this point and and they come from a very
broad range of sort of philosophies with
regards to their investment in trip tech
but all of them are interested in the
financial opportunity as well as the
social impact so you know where they
fall on the spectrum is different as
well as you know where social ventures
fallen on the spectrum would you do you
believe that all problems can be solved
with profit maximization or are there
some that necessarily fall on the other
end on the nonprofit side I can ask Jeff
they're all problems of the world
although I'm saying me we have found
some selection of solutions that are
able to accomplish both so where we who
fits on the other side that they can't
meet those requirements there's hard
double requirements yeah I think I think
often other other great social sectors
many education opportunities become
difficult there's a lot of community
service or lower income areas and a lot
of finance areas that there's a lot of
many many segments that would have
tremendous benefit but they did but you
know I think the notion of solving it
for profit you know even nonprofits need
Brotman they need cash flow then your
business models so I think all of them
need to be thinking through as Russ was
saying what they're you know how to how
to run an organization and if I can add
a perspective on that about a month ago
Lucy Byrne Holtz who's a fellow at SEMA
I had a classmate na there's an
interdisciplinary program here at
Stanford called philanthropy and civil
society and so she's a fellow associated
with that she would maintain that as
you're looking at this spectrum that it
used to be that there was almost a
monopoly on the delivery of social value
you had to be a 501c3 you had to be pure
nonprofit that and she would maintain
that one of the big revolutions it's
really not particularly understood or
well recognized but is going on in a
major way right now is that monopoly is
now broken and there are emerging
different forms of organization one of
them you may hear called l3c which is a
low-profit LLC that and as regular
for-profit companies say no we can do
social value and because we do that we
can actually do a better job of
recruiting employees because they'll
like our mission or or will get more
inspiration out of them or we can attack
certain things that other that you're
going to see that social value being
delivered across a much broader spectrum
so that monopoly has been broken
I do think by the way that even though
it's broken there will still be some
efforts that have to be tackled by pure
humanitarian efforts but it will be much
more of a spectrum than it's been I was
just taking an extremist
so okay let's say I'm an individual
investor okay and I have a bucket of
money that I think of as my
philanthropic dollars and a bucket of
money that I invest for gain and now I
see this really cool company that is
doing mission as well as profit and
maybe there's a little trade-off that I
have to make am I going to take if I
want to invest in them am I going to
take those dollars out of my
philanthropic bucket am I going to take
it out of my investment bucket how do
how should people think at an individual
and also at an organization level how do
you think where those dollars coming
from for those companies that maybe
aren't able to do both as well that are
having to fall in the gray area a little
bit is there a new capital is there a
new spot in the middle if there is I
think but it's it's going to be slower
to evolve on the individual side except
for the fact that I mean if you look at
venture capital and the way that's
evolved and that really is sort of the
institutionalization of investing in
small dynamic entrepreneurs on the
social side were not yet there where we
have organized funds or in my case of
fun to funds that can invest in that and
part of that I think is structural there
may not be enough if you may be doing a
great job on obesity but you don't touch
environment or you don't touch poverty
or you may touch all but which bucket do
you belong in it so you can't really
aggregate enough of these together to
aggregate the investors to be able to do
it so I think the bulk of the capital
and this is still a little bit of a game
to watch is coming from foundations as
they may have heard that they're
mandated to give away the 5% but the
other 95% there's a fellow that was 'red
staffers at Emerson that would say if
you don't deploy that 95 percent of that
corpus of that you have it becomes
morbid capital just deadly just sitting
there and may even fight against your
mission that you're trying to accomplish
so can you mobilize that 95 percent and
I think there's enough of building
groundswell in that you're going to see
some foundations not just right now
there are few signature ones they've
come over but I think there's more with
Kellogg's entrance edge and Tom Reese is
just going gung-ho at this he's going to
give Kurtz to others so it's it's really
growing from just a very narrow
edge Stolz don't really but I'm
convinced that that will be our first
group that will do it I mean the reason
I asked about the individual is it's the
individual who funds eventually into the
venture capital funds that then make
those decisions and until the individual
is willing to make some trade-offs the
fund has to abide by whatever the
investors want yeah I'm not you know I
um the reason why I started a venture
capital fund was because of this dynamic
so I did I made a bunch of money and
then i started doing angel investments
so i get like 20 business plans and you
know how'd you do it and will you help
them can be investment advice and you
know i'd make like you know four or five
investments and it's crazy it's crazy
you're not professional do you know so
at Catamount we look at twelve hundred
business plans a year and we invest in
two or three companies and so you know I
think that there are professionals that
do this on both the social
not-for-profit side as well as on the
for-profit side and I'm not a big fan of
angel investing I think that you're just
going to be taking bets it takes not
just money it takes a lot of money in
some cases to get these companies going
and angels typically don't have it it
takes a lot of energy and work and a
place and experience I mean it's just
like you got to get in there and help
help these folks out I mean they're
working their ass off and it's not easy
and so anything it takes so I think for
it for individuals I would say go find a
great manager that you believe in and or
go find a great foundation or go find a
great fund of funds that has their
similar philosophy that you want to
achieve okay I'd say let me just say the
flip side of that is as often you know
what kind of capital is stage
appropriate right so you know we
actually did get bounced around between
you know in within organizations from
the foundation to the to the business
development you know category back and
forth though you don't quite fit here go
over there go over and you know as a
start-up you need to move quickly and
angels can move quickly so obviously as
we as we look at you know who's going to
take us the distance
and how we're sort of framing up our a
round you know we need institutions that
can provide that additional value add um
but but I was very pleased with with our
angels and spread that tactic in general
I mean is this visit the comment
basically is that the venture capital
community you would think is great risk
takers but it is so unbelievably
conservative and typically as an
entrepreneur and having raised money for
three companies I mean they will show us
the business plan show us the the
customers show us your product show us
the team show us everything and then
we'll maybe think about investing like I
just got to get this thing off the
ground so catting our motto at Catamount
is nothing's too early for us I mean
we're looking for an entrepreneur and a
business plan to get going because of
that dynamic that angels can get in
there and be more nimble when
entrepreneurs need that help you know
that's that's very and foundation more
views you should be like that and if
these these are conservative they would
foundations would consider VCS Mavericks
because even though there's a
philosophical view that says we as a
society allow foundations to exist and
they ought to be society's risk capital
they ought to do some of these
pioneering things but yet foundations
themselves are very conservative and
especially if you're sitting in a
program office if we force our program
officers and foundations to make these
decisions they almost believe that
there's this barrier that they should
never cross which is to be so close to
an it you know a venture capitalist
believes they need to be close to an
investment program officers need to
believe or believe they needed the hands
off so they're dispassionate and that
there's a very big cultural design and
as much as they may think of venture
capitalists as Mavericks you know I mean
is so conservative what I then compared
to what these guys do there are a
hundred and ten percent in one company I
have ten you know that are you know
going up and down at different times
I've done that I know what being
American it's like it's hard so um I
want to ask how do all of you measure
social or environmental return and how
do you compare yeah when we start that
how do you measure that heading for us
um you know we take our standards that
we're feeding to our students every day
and try to really benchmark those
against
you know standards that we believe in I
mean for instance it was it was great
for us because Robert Wood Johnson which
is obviously one of the kind of leading
foundations in terms of health and
wellness their obesity Commission which
looked at schools came out with their
kind of top ten recommendations of what
they would do to change American schools
if they could the food programs in
American schools and we kind of
cross-check those I mean to a tee that's
you know had been red food standard
operating approach with our schools in
terms of the food standards and the
nutrition education that we've been
providing since inception but we you
know we're really we think about those
standards really really carefully
implement them every day and then really
for us it's a matter of scale right so
if we can get I mean we grew from 500
meals to 50,000 meals in the last four
years across four markets and you know
we look at those meals going out the
door every day and the fact that these
are students were these are they're
reliable meals of the day if you think
about serving breakfast lunch and snack
it's a lot of calories for the students
we're serving so we measured in terms of
scale and impact are you measuring the
impact on obesity well so we don't have
a technical sort of research partner
we're not we're not equipped internally
to be taking BMIs and weighing students
etc but we may go that direction what we
have right now is an amazing amazing
depth of testimonials from our schools
around students losing an executive
director the other day just told me you
know literally sees two student slimming
down before his eyes students with
increased attention to class and the
afternoons less disciplinary action on
the playground because they've had a
balanced you know well nourished lunch
instead of kind of spiking up and down
we hear stories all the time every day
ho most the testimonial comes in around
a student bringing a healthy eating
practice home to his or her parents so
we think about when you're trying to
build lifelong healthy eating habits you
know we are amassing those testimonials
and using them to go out there and
obviously scale our program and market
our program and yeah we're looking at
that impact day in and day out it's
tough to get hard measurement but you've
got the good anecdotal
you've got great anecdotes and we
actually have had multiple schools in
the last year say just yesterday from
Colorado school saying principal saying
our test scores have gone at we've had
the biggest jump in test scores we've
had since we founded this school and the
one tangible difference I know happened
from last year was my switch to
revolution foods that came in from Axel
Academy yesterday in Colorado now I
don't have Harvard backing me up on that
but I guess you know those stories are
well yep Stanford that's great I'm so
sorry my gosh it's just a class I don't
why I'm saying it but anyways but I
think that's I say that because planet
health at Harvard has been reaching out
to us about doing a study but I think
that's really really important that me
okay got it Peter first you know
obviously Kristen touched on this a lot
is is that you know metrics and
measurement is hard and and there's a
you know as a million things to do so
it's really a balance of what is sort of
appropriate both from you know the needs
of the company to measure their their
their effectivity and make sort of
course corrections the needs in terms of
marketing and and delivering information
to our investors and stakeholders for us
because as I said the the social impact
is really in the product our our key
metric is really that number of
customers that we can that we can
attract because since we're selling this
profitably it's really about the value
proposition that we're providing to
these customers that they're willing to
pay their own money to purchase it and
that's a that's a big credential that so
that's really kind of like our our
metric and we think about how are we
going to get that you know maximum
number of farmers if they can pay for it
then they're getting a greater return
right they're making their own economic
decisions they're saying this value
proposition makes sense for me it's an
investment and then that's the sort of
the ultimate metric for us that was
easier than
some of the others how about how about
you Jen yeah well I mean we encourage it
in every one of our companies and and
and and are doing it ourselves in fact
we're just redoing our website to to
highlight the impact of what we're doing
and so I think it's a very it's a very
important question and if it the ways of
measuring success are increasingly more
scientific and more difficult and and
extremely important so you know I was
just listening a couple of our companies
but at Werdum they have a power
management software company that shuts
down big networks of PCs to save energy
costs and a part of their value
proposition is the carbon emission
reduction and you know they save 40,000
tons of reductions just from Citigroup
alone by using their product and seventh
generation has a whole area on their
website were the very public about the
impact of using their products that
people that used to use the paper towels
that have bleach and chemicals that are
polluting all these rivers does that
many tons that are no longer no longer
doing that ever evolution foods in the
number of kids you know that how many
meals have you served at one and a half
million oh seven seven million okay so
here fast the girl um and and you know
this company called pure cents we're
looking at the puts monitors in the
ground to help farmers figure out
whether they're using enough water in
different parts of their of their firms
and it's interesting that in the end
they don't save water but they increase
the yield by having more more to go here
and let's go there and so they think
these kinds of measurements are critical
and if you think it was tough to do the
measurement at the individual level put
yourself in a in the seat of someone
that's trying to do multiple ones of
these I think on the radio today I was
listening to some foundation that was an
underwriter and they had a nice what
sounded like a nice simple tagline into
something like you know to bring about a
cleaner healthier and more peaceful
planet or something like that but any
one of those things is you could have a
metric for each one of them and then be
tough tough to do you know something
some of the ones that focus in and
energy foundation is done of they'll try
to measure how many tons of you know
sulfur dioxide did they take out and so
they'll try to get a mono
measure of what they do but it's very
tough and it's still an early discipline
that investors are putting into this
area one of the better efforts is
actually promoted by a Stanford graduate
Jacqueline Novogratz who runs acumen
fund who's grabbed a bunch of the free
time of Google engineers and put
together a portfolio management tool
that allows them to not just keep track
of the investments in the returns but
what are they doing on the social
measure and so she's got something I've
added about five of our of my investors
are working on that tool and using it
and a beta site but even if you have a
tool and even you're certain to measure
something you know just to give you a
sense of how painful this is or how
tough it is you know the early efforts
start to measure activity you know did
we feed someone or did we feed them less
you know sugar than they had before
right
well then once you get that under
control you try to say well that's good
let's look at efficiency or productivity
you know how many meals per square
dollar or how many you know family meals
per full-time equivalent person yeah how
are we doing effectiveness avoid so not
just are we feeding people but are we
doing it with the resources we have and
out all right well that's that's good
that's still a point in time how about
effectiveness
you know if we're trying to actually
eliminate obesity or trying to get
people off poverty are we reaching that
goal and so you know number of bed nets
delivered a number of you know all these
things are good indicators but toward an
end and we're still struggling as a
sector for how to move to an ultimate
measurement and even when you get to
that how do you do it in a
cost-effective way so it doesn't burden
your grants
too much so that it becomes a
unproductive to even do that
so put that into context for you the
good news is there's there's good stuff
happening but it is a tough tough
process okay
so how do you two
protect your mission you might we've got
this great social value inherent in your
product but you could sell it Peter
could sell his drip irrigation for more
in the US he can maybe cut some corners
on some manufacturing Kristin could add
in crab mac and cheese to reduce her
cost you know what how do you how do you
make sure that long term your minissha
mission is protected maybe if you're no
longer with the organization or
something
well it's that's really tricky I mean
that's something that that uh been
injury struggle but we're trying to
figure it and I met one of the one of
the guys at Ben & Jerry's at net impact
and talked to him about it a little bit
I I don't know if I have an answer to
that I think that the key is is in the
team that you attract and then and then
trying to build your brand to be
consistent with the mission so that it's
a rust rust give me a hint that's it's
you know building your company culture
so yeah that it has to do with the brand
and the team and and and you know just
the day-to-day so that if a few sort of
step back you know hopefully you've got
it to the point where things kind of run
on their own and I'll add to brandon
team to also to investors I think it's
so important that you've got you know
investors that are aligned with what
you're trying to accomplish you're not
just you know waffling back and forth
constantly so that's that's been a
really important part of building our
company definitely agree with team and I
just I go back to brand as well I mean I
I sat in the room with a large large
competitor yesterday and the reason
they're so interested in talking to us
at our tiny little you know they said
we've got we have 250 employees they
have 250,000 employees that was like the
first comparison of the slides but um it
just
the reason it's all about brand right
it's the fact that if we like everything
we've built around our social mission
and who we serve and the standards that
we have and why we think that's
important and the demand that that's
created in the marketplace that's all
wrapped in to revel
foods the brand and that's what's that's
what's given us you know the value that
we have or the value that we're building
obviously and so that's that's how we
protect it is it's what we are it's who
we are okay quick comment I I think one
of the most important things we do as
investors is to ensure a lot of the
alignment of interests and it's not just
on the mission it gets to mission
company but it's on everything on exits
on growth on you know making sure that
you have everyone around the board
everyone around the team as much as
possible going down the same path but
the same mission thinking about what the
company wants to achieve and as soon as
you start inserting people that have
their own stuff that they want to throw
in or their own needs that are different
it falls apart so you need to have as
much but you can't get them completely
in line because people have their own
personal stuff and you know I have my
investors they want returns and say this
just interests going to be out of line a
little bit so I would just say as much
as possible I'm gonna ask one more
question and then open it up to the
floor so we have two very ideal social
enterprises here who say that they don't
need to manage the conflict between
profit and mission because its inherent
in their product I would contend that
that is not always the case that there
are plenty of cases where you have to
make trade-offs if you have to sacrifice
some amount of profit to achieve your
mission I think a good example of that
is if you're trying to you know if we go
back to the slide in the employment side
of things if you're trying to employ you
know one of your parts of your mission
is employing disabled or employing
people who or premium previously
unemployable you put something in your
cost structure that raises your cost so
there's number a number of times you're
going to have to make a trade-off
depending where your value is so for
those kinds of organizations what advice
would you
investors have for them where do they go
how do they position it they may not be
able to maximize profits they may have
slightly lower returns what should they
do well I I as I said earlier I think
they absolutely have to make those
sacrifices and decisions every single
day so I think that you know whether its
packaging or what food you I'm sure you
deal with it all the time so what food
ingredients are you going to put in and
what are the healthiest possible
solutions you may not be able to
actually do that so no I agree with you
and the only thing I'd add is is as Jed
would say things things change they
change in fundamental ways if you can't
even predict necessarily out the market
or the the competition it is and so your
your ultimate sort of comfort as an
investor is probably the management team
and to the extent that they're able to
have a compass and a culture that's
going in the direction you feel
comfortable with and that's why it's not
just show us a great business plan show
us a great market it's let us get
comfortable with that team and that
you're going to hire the right people
that will continue to grow in it and so
that's why I think good investors do
spend time trying to understand the
character of the of the management team
literally no I know are there investors
who mean you believe there are investors
who will take less return in exchange
for more social impact yeah yes and
where are they who are they well I mean
they're there there are there are some
that have very clear mission oriented
funds there's a seafood fund and there
there are people that are very very
focused on very specific sectors that
may not have the best possible returns
but they care about that sector and
their investors know that the investors
in the funds know in advance of their
trip making them well I don't know you
probably see ya there there aren't as
many I mean it's still a small price
mall part but there are some the dbl
fund what was first the Bay Area equity
fund now now called dbl is one of those
is this a growing segment of the capital
market or not
do it I mean I guess if you say it used
to be that all mission stuff came out of
nonprofits now we're seeing a trend
perhaps well maybe I can actually run it
as a for-profit I'm still primarily
mission but I've got a good revenue
stream my profits aren't going to be as
high I think I should make a go of it
that's great we I mean we want them to
go for it so where do they go for funds
and how do we make a capital market it
works for them yeah I think I feel like
you're talking very broadly about
socially focused funds and and so there
are a lot of them they're smaller
they're emerging but I think that what
I'm seeing is more funds that are kind
of doing the kinds of things that we are
that see fantastic capital opportunities
that also happen to have great returns
my fear is that some of the socially
oriented ones may over-promised the
returns focusing on mission and then
their investors will be unhappy and then
that money will dry up so I do think
this is can be a turning point and it's
all a matter of setting the right
expectations okay questions
so yourself and for your vision of
change someone who is likely have let
have everything they need very lightly
is not affected by that problem new
trends like Goldman differently than
they need infinite flooring so how do
you do that pictures are good story
stories I think that you do have to find
ways to to connect the person you're
selling whether it whether it's your
investor or you're just the person
you're you're you're talking to it I
mean water food it's pretty simple look
you know people people share these these
needs around the world and they can they
can you know empathize with people
around the around the world that don't
have those have access to those so I
guess I would say market opportunity I
mean if you're going into someone and
saying I see a market opportunity that
looks like X and you're able to you know
back that up and at the same time you
know talk about what an incredible
social impact you would have I think
those are the two strongest factors that
you can talk to an investor about so
it's just a quick addition depends on
the audience yeah it depends on the
audience um okay what goes back to an
earlier conversation about how much how
important it is to get interest in line
get investors that care about your
mission get board members of care about
your main get employees to care about
your mission so if you're talking
someone that doesn't care about it and
you're talking to the wrong person so
you want to as much as possible qualify
before you go in that meeting so you're
not wasting your time and I think of I
think of our company as sort of a whole
picture of for-profit and social impact
and there are some people that we talk
to that only want to hear about part of
that and and that's fine that's their
prerogative
hey it's very nice here to see your very
inspiring companies so I can use the
filters room I was a question actually
for kids you were talking about it you
accomplished which get 10% of the
property
nice a smart social responsibility
Institute it loves where you choose
these charities and he ultimately
promotes economy
we promoted on this is seventh
generation that does that in particular
and there are a few others that have
gotten to scale where they they can do
it but seventh generation has been a
leader in this area and it's actually a
pretty significant number ten percent
and they put it on every package of
every product that they sell and they
have an internal team foundation team
that that takes in requests for
donations that pull up all across three
different sectors one is their local
community where they're based in
Burlington Vermont the other is
sustainable environmental mission kinds
of companies and they also and as
important percentage generation is to
health impact so they look at health
health
six years Lyme disease
you know that our country in the media
by the Green Revolution scenes and in 67
in order to increase activity
the surplus of rice but after that the
productivity because cantilever easy
because there's a lot of synthetic
chemical like in our soil and a society
then
in the damage the soil again soil so
ready yeah we have this one below one
point seven five years isn't only
increased chemical fertilizer for
whatsoever
and just want to ask you about air
pollution food blasts well I certainly
think definitely so I didn't get a
chance to state our food standards but I
mean our food standards all of our meats
and dairy products are hormone and
antibiotic-free we use fresh fruits and
vegetables and every meal we don't use
any added preservatives or high fructose
corn syrup which isn't so much of the
you know processed food that you see
everywhere but really we focus on fresh
homestyle food not as Jed said we're not
able to do a hundred percent organic but
to the extent that we can work with
local farmers and use seasonal produce
and you know source from our local
community we do that and we have a
really really strong commitment to doing
that so I do think it's it's similar in
the sense that we're trying to get you
know more fresh food into our
communities and in most cases these are
very underserved communities so you know
very very closely related I'm going to
show the Velo and creating a high
transparency ethical bank actually
understand kind of blend is part of our
underwriting both sides or all sides
of the bee impacts that enterprises
because my question is really simple
we're living through dual prices a
climate crisis not banking price and I
just wonder you know at one point you
are affected whether yet because of
young where you see your growth being
affected by constraints in the
neighborhood of the system you know you
can talk about equity like one but you'd
like to be able to scale anything with
bank debt of some flavor or another to
get to leverage what what are you must
variance in what do you pull it up how
are you gonna use that opportunity space
you have them running we couldn't we
have some companies yeah I guess one
thing to know would be that our
investment that we've raised so far is
actually all in the form of convertible
debt although that's that's not
institutional debt but that's something
that we're looking hopefully forward to
in the future but the trick is you know
even before the current financial
climate finding finding finding
commercial debt that was available for
our types of ventures was was incredibly
difficult so the I haven't seen a real
shift because it's you know finding
somebody who can finance say you know
our product that's being shipped around
and capital investments in other
countries for manufacturing facilities
and that kind of thing I'm not sure that
that's really well developed yet
regardless of the financial climate
we we haven't really gotten to that kind
of that kind of level yet but but but we
will we'll be exploring all kinds of you
know any kind of way that we can balance
our our capital you know with debt and
equity so we're actually at an
interesting stage where we are
considering dead Fred small being a
strategic loan from Whole Foods and some
some great kind of small debt along the
way but we are finding you know a lot of
appetite at this juncture for no pun
intended but um for what for what we're
doing in this stage we're at given our
growth and kind of how our operations
and financials look one of the most
promising things I think for us is um
looking at you know as as we grow into
new markets more beneficial financing
structures debt structures that come
from you know the job creation for
instance that we will contribute to that
community if we are able to go in and
start you know building a Culinary
Center and serving the students in that
community so you know I'd love to answer
that question in a year but I'm feeling
good about the opportunities that exist
right now I think I think that the debt
market for earlier stage companies is
completely cyclic cyclical and you know
when things are everything's going up
into the right there's plenty of it
available and as soon as there's a
contraction there the first grab capital
back and in many ways can kill a company
probably good for the bank's business
model but debt can be extremely risky
and so in 2000 in 1999 and 2000 there
was more debt than you can imagine that
was available at unbelievably favorable
terms and in 2002 it was absolutely the
worst business to be and and they were
just walking around sweeping cash out of
companies just to be able to cover
themselves and then in 2004 or five and
six it started to kind of pick back up
again and we were seeing a lot more term
sheets and then started to pull back and
so I think the short story is that as
company
and as investors and board members you
need to be extremely thoughtful about
when you take it on because you last
thing you want is to break it in a
covenant and then everything gets ruined
and and the loners need to be extremely
thoughtful about about it as well so
it's a I think it's a tough industry
it's like with any venture stay very
very focused I've solved in a specific
pain and firstly here for both founders
and the financial side how important you
see it is to stay focused when you see a
broader market and and you stick to the
focus or do you go broad earlier - well
I'll take that so so I think that that's
something that was really pretty
critical for us was that we didn't
really set out to start a company we've
set out to solve a problem so you know
when I when I met these farmers that
needed low-cost drip irrigation I saw an
opportunity to develop a manufacturing
technology that would solve that problem
and and without thinking about a
business model or a plan or or market or
anything like that I went out and did
solve the problem and got sort of our
functional prototype and then only when
when we sort of realized what we've done
did it did we start to consider well wow
this might have some legs beyond just a
project just a technology this this
could become a you know company and so I
definitely believe that that focus is
incredibly important okay I think I
think it's critical we had a really
interesting moment at revolution foods
where and we started up with our focus
on schools and health and wellness and
sure enough our strategic partner Whole
Foods came to us and said we love the
mission behind this company we feel like
consumers would buy into the mission
behind this company and so we'd like for
you guys to launch a consumer products
line and here and I looked at each other
and said this is something great
opportunity something we have very
little experience in and it could be an
entire operating division right now of
our company and were one I think we're
one year old maybe we were nine months
old I mean we were really young when
they first approached us so we you know
took a good hard look and pow well with
our investors and board and you know
decided this it just makes more sense to
form a strategic partnership on this and
have some experts who are really really
good at this helped us develop this and
innovate this and really make this
successful
and that's when we we partnered with
nest naturals and so that's I mean I
just have a very tangible example about
kind of you can well of course I want to
take a slightly contrarian view because
I've been in a number of startups as
well and as Jed was talking about cycles
if you are in a good cycle and the money
is available and the opportunities are
available I would say it's you don't
know when you start a company you don't
know exactly if you're on the right
focus rate and if a great opportunity
comes your way and you have the
resources to go after it sometimes I
mean I was with them it was as a
for-profit Verisign when there was you
know a ten eighty eighty thousand
dollars in revenue we didn't know what
was going to work and we had enough
money and we were at a really good time
we could try five different business
models and we tried them all and you
know three or four of them worked and I
don't think we would have been
successful had we just stuck with the
very one thing that we'd started with so
it's a cyclical thing and an opportunity
but I think generally you do want to be
super focused but I think there are
times when you can be opportunity and go
for it that's a hallway look at it I
think we highly encourage everyone to be
really focused on who's your target
customer what are you offering them are
you making are you satisfying them and
the reason why Kristin and Kherson were
able to say you know
we we can't do the consumer product
stuff was because what they were focused
on was doing so unbelievably West and
there was an enormous market and they
pretty do that they knew it they're like
weed let's just go that way we're good
at it let's make those people happy
this may be great but we have enough of
a big business there all the while
having a company that has a culture of
innovation of experimenting you know
that doesn't squash that you know but
but still you know it's a pretty animal
I think often in the case that I'm
thinking of we had more of a technology
right which is a load which could be
more like Peters case you have a
technology you think it's going to apply
here there might be multiple uses and
you need to kind of try Mac and similar
and Verisign that the if you worked at
Dana heaven but the former CFO of Zahra
signs on the board of a company with me
called second life Linden Lab which is a
company that I started with another guy
ten years ago and that company was a
platform like Verisign and a platform
you want it you really trying to do
everything or actually you're trying to
not do anything trying to just do the
platform so everybody can do everything
on top of it and so that dynamic of are
you a product are you a platform are you
a company how big is the market if
you're just a product is a big enough
market to really Boren you putting your
energy towards it is a very interesting
dynamic depending what you're looking at
the last thing you want is someone to
come in that says I'm the Google for
eBay what you know just you don't try to
do everything in West Keene if I get one
more thing just a jolt but you may be
going through it the first time or maybe
the second time but if this is a plug
for jet and his crew they've probably
seen hundreds of these things some of
them unsexy me and if you look at if
they look through to the thousand
business plans per year you know it may
not be your business but isomorphic lee
there's kind of progressions of growth
and when do you add and when do you get
more capital and what do you do they
they have kind of a lot more judgment
and how to do that so you may not have
that they may not have that that's one
of the the real value added he's not
just money he's experience and wisdom
that comes
alongside to say you know it's time to
think about you know I know we're
watching every dollar but now now is the
time to invest in the Salesforce and now
is the time to invest in they're going
to have that and so don't be afraid to
say I don't know but but someone someone
on my advisory board should know yeah
and really really think about investors
with operating experience really really
do that yeah I have a started
something's a 501 C 3 because they buy
job success US military veteran so since
that time I've discovered that there's a
huge market out and getting a lot of
good receptivity companies and say well
hey you to provide services staffed by
veterans worth of their homes so this
all of a sudden I'm finding oh man
English maybe I made the wrong decision
about they restricted or limited myself
in unnecessary ways by making this a 501
C 3 so I'm finding myself in position
where the gift shop is bigger than the
museum and so what do I do now we're not
solving world hunger so it's not as
compelling and and I when we find
capital to fund we're looking to fund a
pilot you know to basically bring in
some key people and make this thing you
know create a sustainable delivery model
so we can show up as incredible
providers and so I'm kind of stuck in
this limbo financing but I believe that
I'm you're kind of stuck have you
written a plan yeah a for-profit plan I
guess I'm not his guidance it's tilted
toward the social empowerment but it
definitely highlights where your income
is really going to sustain I've always
found that at least in my experience as
an entrepreneur it definitely is
invested as an entrepreneur that as soon
as you start writing then you know what
you know and you know what you don't
know you start asking yourself how big
is the market what do I charge you know
how many people care about it what else
do they care about what's their pain am
i solving it is am i solving it in a
unique way that other people can't when
they get into it and then you start kind
of asking that and then out of that
you'll you'll get more conviction about
whether it's an enormous opportunity or
medium or small and who might be the
best possible people to reach out to
they care about the kind of thing that
you're trying to you might want to write
two plans one that's on the for-profit
side and see how you know and kind of
pushed through the tough questions on
that from that perspective and one the
other way and you see kind of which one
makes more sense
you could also shop those in on 50 other
question yes yeah that's a great
question so obviously when you're trying
to distribute your product in India or
China that's a huge challenge for our
pilot studies it was pretty easy we
basically just showed up and started
kind of looking weird and and walking
around and people kind of came out of
their houses and said that they try our
drip irrigation but you know obviously
like is that sort of as we proved the
product and and you don't need to scale
that up we're looking at commercial
distribution channels nonprofit
organizations our first sale in China
was actually the to a rural government
which basically we came to them and said
you know you know they provide a lot of
the inputs for their these local farmers
they're kind of the primary stakeholder
and so they were very interested in
getting the farmers to increase their
income and reduce inputs so that was
kind of like a first sale and
interesting business model in in China
in India we probably want to work more
with commercial distribution channels
and it turns out that you know even the
most rural farmers that we've that we've
met with they still have access to the
seeds and fertilizer and and and
hardware that the large-scale farmers
have access to so those are the channels
we're looking at so to respect
everybody's time well in the panel I
imagine panelists are willing to stay
for a few minutes and maybe
want to come down and that's many other
questions thank you